thank you very much for having me today
so this is my first time doing a DCR
function and I tell you what it's been
absolutely fabulous coming from the
military side of the house it's
definitely a little bit more stuffy or
button-down shirt suits ties feeling
like I should be in board shorts and
flip-flops versus a full military
uniform is actually an outstanding
experience but that being said I'm gonna
talk a little bit today kind of a little
bit more squishier and not as many
technical as the the speaking
opportunities prior to me I'm going to
focus on a certain type of Defense
analysis and the teams that I have put
together to try and get after it how I'm
going to portray what I think is the
right way to do it isn't necessarily a
standardized way nor is it really the
views of everybody in the in the
Pentagon or in department defence but I
feel I've had great success doing it
this way
and I'm just going to talk about the
complexities of it and then some of the
issues that we see within the Department
of Defense of trying to actually
implement it to do really good analysis
first thing I'm gonna ask him to pose a
question to the group say you have a
heart attack and you get rushed to the
hospital do you want that doctor
immediately to start operating on you so
I see everybody saying how do I know
that that's the right kind of doctor is
it that pediatrician is it an eye doctor
is it a foot doctor everybody has a
specialty and everybody has a role in
being able to do the best work they can
for the common good analysis should be
looked at the same way not everybody
brings the same set of skills to provide
the same part type of end product and we
need to know how to organize and operate
to be to effectively do that mission in
the Navy data science is kind of a black
box it's just starting to to emerge but
you're hearing it touted widely and
loudly from the most senior executives
within all the services and in the
department what they don't realize is
the military has done operations
research which incorporates parts of all
of the data science fields mathematics
statistics but then merges that with
really the warfighter and in his subject
matter expertise on weapon systems to
try and better basically use how we
fight and and how we we win and succeed
in combat the trick is though that makes
us a little bit of a generalist so we
know a little bit about a lot but not a
lot about everything so what we really
need to do is make sure we maximize who
we have participating in our analytic
efforts to really get the deep subject
matter expertise and provide the best
product that's got the right rigor the
right level of detail and that just
plainly our assumptions and the way of
doing business is the most efficient
elegant so we put the right weapons on
the right target at the right time by
the right platform against you know an
enemy that's trying to stop us from
doing all of those things non-stop so
the work that I've been doing probably
the last seven years or so is a type of
analysis called campaign analysis people
had a tendency that when they say that
word they think it is one singular tool
and one singular modeling program called
storm which is call is the basically the
synthetic theater operations research
model it is a very large clunky
stochastic model that runs thousands of
times with about a million lines of code
that what it does is it a grits every
single dimension of warfare from
cyberspace airpower naval surface power
ground undersea and it incorporates both
the blue forces which is us the red
forces which is whoever your your
adversary is and then potentially if the
the sponsor or the studies designed to
explore what the contributions from
allies and partners would be so all of a
sudden you've got like a three large
multi dimensional problem and this thing
gets ugly very very fast what we're
trying to do though is create a way that
is repeatable tractable and I think we
saw the word earlier credible so that
way we
inform the warfighter to figure out how
to best fight his force and then to to
help inform the budgeteers
and kind of more importantly the folks
on this side of the river over here on
the hill when they say do I buy more
submarines or Lam I buy more Strike
Fighters you need a way that you can
pose to them while you're deciding what
to do and how much of it to buy you're
talking about billion dollar decisions
and there needs to be a way to
understand and analyze how those things
all interact together so you can
actually procure what you need to
procure and the most efficient means
possible now with that being said I'll
caveat write-once it kind of goes into
the bureaucratic calculator all fair
right so who's got what going on or who
has what you know rice bowl that they
want to protect or whatnot this is where
you can kind of really go sideways fast
our job is to provide that
decision-maker though with the most
unbiased decision-making tools in
knowledge to help him inform that
decision so I mentioned a little bit
about the complexity so you kind of have
you know blue red green each one of
those areas has a large trade space
there are hundreds of variables within
each one of those those domains
everything from every single aircraft
every single ship every single ground
unit you can think of as an entity every
one of those entities has a host of
attributes that are assigned to it
everything from how it sees the
environment how it interacts with the
environment how fast it is how slow it
is how long does it take to burns fuel
how does it see the enemy then it go you
could take it a step further what
weapons are on board that entity that
are associated with it how do they see
the enemy how did they shoot at the
enemy how many of them do you have and
all of that has to happen in a geography
at a space in point in time so now you
start overlaying all those variables all
of the distributions of variation on
every one of those variables and try and
build a black box to be able to tell you
we will beat you on day 5 with this
force that's never going to
happen that is not the intent of this
analysis the end of the day this
analysis is merely designed not to be
predictive but to be quantitative in a
way that allows me to show and create
relationships about orders of magnitude
I want to be able to show that if it
takes 10 things of me to do something to
you it takes you five things to counter
it it builds relationships to understand
how we are interacting with the
adversary and then it also creates
conditions about which how our force
operates so if I want to do submarine
warfare very close to an enemy's
operation area I may need to do things
in that operating environment to create
the conditions for those submarines to
operate so it starts to build out
quantitatively and understand where are
my first order second order third in so
on conditions and those relationships
defined by the math right of what needs
to happen when and where in time to help
us kind of shape and organize by the
time you get done in the calculator here
you have a huge problem one of the
things that we'll see and I'll talk
about in a minute though is how do you
figure out where to start from
there's so many variables so many
combinations and you've got a limit
amount of resources there's no way
combinatorially I can actually do all
the variations and all that space right
if I ran a design of experiments I could
take everybody's computer here give you
about a thousand course and give you to
the end of all of our lifetimes and that
thing would still be turning away so
Naval Postgraduate School has done a lot
of work and they have come up with
nearly a flat nearly orthogonal Latin
hypercubes
to try and create space filling design
of experiments but even with that you
really can't get after the amount of
trade space we're talking about here the
other part is a lot of that strace trade
space is operationally infeasible so now
you've got to think about from the
operational perspective but not only the
combinatorics the combinations so just
because the math says we can put these
things together space base and time
doesn't necessarily mean operationally
we would want to do that so there's this
now you're starting to integrate this
subject matter expertise of your
operators into this mix
so the process I made it as cartoonish
as it can be because I'm usually talking
to general officer and flag officers
I'll leave it at that so with that being
said on the right hand side here or your
left hand side you will see 14 or so
different topical areas those are kind
of big high level warfare areas and you
can see it's everything from air for
fare down to logistics so how do you get
you know rip it's and diet coke and you
know all the necessities to the
warfighter oh by the way you might want
gas too and weapons right to be able to
do all this in space and time so we need
to take subject matter expertise folks
that know how to do this and have
operated in this world to kind of enter
into the equation so there's there's
ground rule one right we need people
that have subject matter expertise we
then feed into this middle area here and
this is what I call concepts of
operation development this is where we
build the tactical level understanding
of how we organize and operate the force
to do a particular mission set and I say
mission set it can range in complexity
from literally me picking up a rifle and
shooting something like at the backside
of this room that's the most tactical
instance you can get very singular
dimensions not a lot going on one-on-one
too much more complicated scenarios
where now I have literally thousands of
things competing at the same time for
space all firing all seeing and doing a
lot of things so there's a whole lot
going on there and I need to build those
organizational structures in rules of
how do I want to employ my aircraft
carrier do I want it to sit at a
thousand miles away from the enemy well
when do I move it from a thousand miles
to 500 miles and when I move with the
500 miles do I want it to run 24 hours a
day or not 24 hours a day should I put
am around in 7m 17s on it or should I
put more surface-to-air missiles on our
service the ground missiles on it so
there's a lot of different complexities
that need to be happened and these
operational guys start to to start to
kind of mold and build that plan out at
a very high level we then take that plan
we throw it into to a war game and so
this is where now we can iterate a
little bit faster or we don't have to
deal with the coding but you can put
them in literally in front of a a paper
map and say if you have this in you have
a readout of Cerie and you're right out
of series is doing it - like how would
this play out it's just it's a way for
us to kind of walk through at a high
level very quickly these concepts of
operation so this is a highly iterative
process and you can go as deep as you
want or as shallow as you want you can
really tailor it to to the work you're
doing from there we've also got to do a
whole bunch of modeling and simulation
work
we've got work that happens at the the
phenomenology level right so you've got
radar systems you've got sonar systems
where you need to understand the
literally the engineering level
phenomenology of the environment you're
operating in how far can I see a low
observable stealth aircraft you know
with a particular type of radar you need
to understand all of that work and you
have to model that in a whole different
range of scenarios to be able to develop
that base level of knowledge after that
you've got to start doing engagement
level knowledge this is where I've got
say a Joint Strike Fighter versus a an
adversary stealth aircraft and they're
literally going mano a mano in the air
and you need to understand how the
entire weapon system of one an abbess or
person works against the the other pilot
and so there's a lot of that goes on
there from there we go into the mission
modeling this is where you start to get
a little bit more complicated if it
wasn't complicated enough already right
this is where now I've got multiple
weapon systems maybe from multiple
domains and when I say domains I mean
maybe you have an aircraft a ship in
ground forces all fighting an adversary
that have ground you know surface and in
Air Force as well but it's in a very
constrained environment so maybe it's
like literally over Washington DC right
you've got this a little bit of
engagement going on and you can control
for the number of variables and the
number of entities but once again it can
grow combinatorially very complex very
quickly from there we move into combat
modeling and simulation
at the campaign level this is where it
gets really complicated this is where
you try to look at aggregating
everything from the layers above and all
of the stuff from the left and
incorporate that into one modeling and
simulation environment
now you're compromising some fidelity
when you do it but what you're doing is
creating an environment that you can
create in a stochastic way thousands of
replications of this interaction of
these large force on large force
engagements and then from that I can
infer a whole litany of things which is
one of the areas where I think we're
actually starting to fall short a little
bit and I'll talk it to you in a minute
so when we're done there we come down
into this campaign analysis and really
the way this should be represented it is
not a discrete block at the end campaign
analysis is actually operations and
analysis that's happening throughout
this entire cycle you're continually
learning you're continually refining and
that all goes into your final set of
analyses so how do you do this right so
like on the left hand side here you've
got Navy SEALs they're they're very
organized they're regimented it's the
team providing the the real horsepower
to be able to carry out the mission on
the right hand side you've got a a Navy
strike group with Air Force aircraft and
Navy aircraft all together to be able to
conduct the mission so it's this
organized structured format but with
diversity right so we don't want a
singular type of person a singular type
of skill set but we need to figure out
how to bring organized structure and
diversity together to be able to find
this product and an end result that's
that's useful so who do we need first
we definitely need Marlon Brando The
Godfather is is key right and so that I
was gonna put Jared's picture up there
especially with the New York data mafia
shirts I thought it would have been
priceless but you need somebody that
just kind of sits at the top and helps
you as you're building out the wargames
as you're building out the CONOPS as
you're doing the modeling simulation
that helps you understand should I go
left or should I go right and then what
are the bounds
I can't underestimate how in
port in this position is and I can't
tell you how often I see analysis when
in department defense that it's not
realized that this is needed I've see it
all the time or I think I see people I
said well he's an or a data scientist he
can do that study director thing to when
that is a very unique skill set you need
to be a project manager right you need
to be able to schedule you need to
understand the operational side of the
house there's a lot of different things
that kind of go into that you know that
chicken soup and so if you think that
anybody can do it I think that's a
fallacy and so this is you know
requirement one in my my SEAL team here
is I need a Marlon Brando I need a
godfather somebody can go kiss the ring
and say boss I want to do this does this
make sense and just does this align with
all the other disparate pieces of
analysis there are probably going on
simultaneously you need that second
thing you need the warfare operators
without these guys it's utterly
impossible to do this an example I have
was I had a an absolutely incredible
incredible data scientist working for me
she was extremely proficient in SAS so
that was kind of her her medium right
and was like if you're comfortable in it
and you could produce the results I need
knock yourself out the problem was she
came from a background where she had
zero operational exposure when you said
aircraft carrier she didn't know if that
was a b-52 airplane right it was to her
it was it was numbers it was it was data
in the in a data warehouse so that was
all less to her it wasn't until I linked
her up with the warfighter when she was
actually doing the post-processing
analysis was she able to actually kind
of start to tease out that the the real
critical insights that was in the data
the data she was showing us in the
analysis she was showing as prior to
that was was almost useless and
insignificant she was making connections
with in ways that were irrelevant right
and so it was only through the the
instance of incorporating the operator
into her kind of cycle of learning that
that really made that different
the next one which people take this for
granted all-time it's it's the wargaming
side of the house this is a real skill
set I mean if anybody who's tried to put
a war game together and facilitate it
and execute it it's it's a skill set
kind of unlike anything else and I can't
tell you how valuable it is to be able
to create a a strategic dilemma or an
operational dilemma for a set of
individuals force them and their
behavior to answer the questions that
you need in in a format of data that you
can then use to then go create a
statistical model or a simulation
environment is absolutely key so this
was the next part of the puzzle that you
need then you need you know Matthew
Broderick right you need the guy who can
sit down a computer terminal and pound
away in the keys and you give them
Doritos and some Mountain Dew and you
just let him rock out right but what
that being said there's a danger in that
because even though you can hand him a
road map of how you think you want the
fight to be incorporated in the computer
I guarantee you within every 30 lines of
code he's going to come up to a place
where he's like hmm is I can't
instantiate this explicitly I need to
create an implicit way for the program
or the model to understand and operate
and depending on his level of
understanding of that operational
environment and of the intent of the
warfighter that can go sideways real
fast so this is another place where that
warfighter needs to be literally left
seat right seat over his shoulder
explaining here's kind of what I want to
do on the battlespace
how do we figure out how to make that
happen inside that computer screen right
it's like Zoolander that you don't
that's the files are in the computer
kind of thing you know we kind of have
to make that happen here the next part
the next person I'm in talk about the
data scientist
if you wanted a different headshot you
should have gave it to me
[Laughter]
so with that being said this is another
person that needs to be involved from
the beginning because at every step of
the way you're trying to learn something
and data is part of that understanding
the operational context in the key
critical questions at the beginning are
paramount so this is I can't
underestimate how important this this
part of the puzzle is and I'm speeding
up here because I'm running a little bit
long
the final part is mr. Rogers right this
is that that person that's been involved
from day one of the study understands
the intent that the study director has
had and then what all of the pieces
along the way were and really
understands those key conclusions back
to the strategic insights that you're
trying to communicate because every
every senior leader needs to be able to
be understand comprehend what you did
why you did it and how is it important
to him this is the guy that wraps that
all together thirty more seconds so when
it all fits together you kind of form
this team of a director the operators
all the way down to the storyteller and
it's really a constant dialogue between
all of them with that said I want to say
thank you extremely I'm extremely proud
to have been here today
Jared mark the whole team thank you so
much
[Applause]